automatically if she has a high body  count and if she is in a relationship  she actually you know loved him and she  been with she gonna sleep automatically  with someone else so easily that doesn't  honestly we should like distinguish  between when you single are you afraid  to do whatever you wish and when you are  in a relationship so it doesn't mean  he's going to be not loyal  it's more likely your habits are who you  are why you need to label someone just  because yeah it's based on your it's not  based on your actions so so same for men  I would say men can actually is actually  allowed to have high body count so what  I what I supposed to think if I'm  actually going to marry the man they  gonna cheat on me